Jeannie I wish to become a prince
[Music]
I see what you doing and see you there
impressive that's Jasmine's mother has
always been a mystery
however the 2019 live-action remake of
Aladdin has brought some new information
to light keep watching to find out who
most likely is behind the sultana's
assassination in the 1992 Disney classic
film Aladdin we meet the royal family of
Agrabah which consists of the Sultan and
his teenage daughter Princess Jasmine if
I do marry I want it to be for love many
of us were left wondering what happened
to the Sultana of Agrabah but hey it's a
Disney movie in the end so we were quick
to accept the fact that Jasmine's mother
was nowhere to be found this all Tana is
mentioned once throughout the film so we
had no reason to believe that this alt
Anna's passing was a tragic one little
is known about Jasmine's mom however we
do know that jasmine and her mother are
carbon copies of each other we mean
they're basically the same person with
different hairstyles we're also aware
that the Sultana was a loving and
artistic woman who inspired the people
of Agrabah and left behind a golden
legacy the Sultana was so loved that we
figured that she passed away from an
illness or something like that
so we think we can speak for everyone
when we say that we were shocked to find
out that the Sultana had been murdered
suddenly the Sultan choosing to keep his
daughter under palace arrest makes
perfect sense there are plenty of
differences between the original Aladdin
film and its live-action remake you
cannot just break into a palace like you
own the place the most notable one being
aladdin and Jasmine first-ever
conversation early on in the movie we
find out the real reason why Princess
Jasmine isn't allowed beyond the palace
walls
Jasmine while in her disguised form
tells Aladdin that the princess hasn't
been allowed to leave the palace walls
ever since the Sultana was murdered
Aladdin goes on to say that the Sultana
was loved by her people and that Agrabah
hasn't felt safe since her passing he
also states that no one in Agrabah would
have hurt the Sultana which has us
sending Jafar some serious sting guys
since this all Tana was beloved by her
people we suspect the Jafar is the one
behind her death
sincere go patient kazeem was obviously
less than worth but what would the
Sultan's Royal vizier gained from
killing the Sultana well a lot of things
for starters we don't find out exactly
how this all Tana passed away but we've
got some ideas
since Jafar wouldn't want to get his
hands dirty it's possible that he chose
to poison her but what if he was trying
to poison the Sultan instead and somehow
missed his mark in the original Adam
film Jafar tried to marry Jasmine in
order to become the Sultan of Agrabah -
what if he was trying to do the same
with the Sultana here's our theory and
it's a little wild both too far and the
Sultana have ties to the kingdom of
Shara bod we know that the Sultan ax
hails from this kingdom and we also know
that Jafar spent five years in a share
of odd jail cell but many of us believe
that he was arrested for thievery is
possible that he was arrested for
something else
what if Jafar was in love with the salt
ana and tried to run away with her but
he got caught and arrested and the
Sultana got married off to the Sultan of
Agrabah then when he was released he
traveled to Agrabah and tried to poison
the Sultan and use his snake staff to
convince the Sultana to marry him
however something happened and the salt
ana is the one who ended up consuming
the poison ever since then Jafar has
been trying to get revenge on the
kingdom of Shara bod because he thinks
it's their fault that the Sultana passed
away while we'd love a good tragic love
story this isn't the only theory we're
going to cover there's also the
possibility that Jafar chose to have the
Sultana assassinated because she made
controlling the Sultan impossible
controlling the Sultan's every move is
something Jafar has mastered over the
years
[Music]
losing his young life and having a baby
girl to take care of was probably a lot
to handle at the time so the Sultan
probably relied on Jafar to get things
done during his grieving period this
would explain why the people of Agrabah
has been afraid ever since the Sultana
was assassinated Jafar has probably been
spreading fear throughout the kingdom
ever since the incident
it sounds like Jasmine's mother was a
super smart lady who is planning to
unite the people of Agrabah and share
Abbas her people genuinely loved her and
respected her vision which simply didn't
fly with a Royal vizier after all he had
a bone to pick with shabbat killing the
Sultana would cause the newly forged
alliance between both kingdoms to waver
which is something too far clearly once
Jafar's motive seems to be revenge and
he'll stop at nothing to wage war on
Shabbat there's also the possibility
that the Sultana found out about Jafar's
evil plans and tried to warn her husband
about them so Jafar had no choice but to
end the salt Ana's life to preserve his
secrecy Jafar is far from being an
innocent Royal vizier he does not have
the kingdoms best interests at heart and
will stop at nothing to eliminate anyone
who gets in his way
during Jafar's villainous monologue he
confesses to having buried many bodies
along the way so since he's killed
before it's hard to believe that Jafar
didn't play a hand in the sawed Ana's
murder by killing Shara bod and a
provides beacon of hope Jafar instilled
fear throughout the kingdoms while
allowing himself to grow more powerful
with Sultana out of the picture Jafar
was able to manipulate the Sultan he
planned to marry off Jasmine to a suitor
who had war on the brain
unfortunately Jasmine didn't want to
marry Prince Anders who most likely
supported Jafar as vision stone do you
guys think that your fire killed
Jasmine's mother if so leave a snake
emoji in the comment section down below
and be sure to tell us why you think the
world Vizier chose to get rid of the
Sultana subscribe to the things for more
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up while you're at it
thanks for watching the things who will
catch you later
[Music]